aber da müssen meine lieben freunde nach
mehreren monaten darf ich euch heute
endlich mal wieder begrüßen zu einer
neuen episode von luca reagiert auf die
doku rudi besten direkt hoch motiviert
in diesem moment
[Musik]
haben wir auch content mit qualität am
start
richtige halle war jetzt musst du jetzt
machst du jetzt tun
qualität ist glaube ich auch in der
heutigen folge wieder ein fremdwort
ich weiß jetzt schon nicht was hier
abgeht
aber die kommt mama
es war irgendwo ja klar
spätestens jetzt fällt mir auf warum ich
dieses format monate lang nicht mehr
hochgeladen habe hat irgendeine person
die ein video mit dem hashtag luca
reagiert auf twitter oder instagram
hochgeladen hat für die heutige folge
nur ein kleines hündchen qualität da
reingesteckt gezogen bin ich ins gesicht
dass er gerne ein
ich bin ein und alles und du bist du
bist mir mehr wert als erstes klar ich
werde immer da sein egal
da sage ich jetzt mal gar nichts zu
[Musik]
schaltern eis genauso einen kotten
möchte ich von euch sehen leute genau
solche videos bitte hochladen mit dem
hashtag luca reagiert also ich glaube
dass wir jetzt wirklich auf einem guten
weg sind die qualität des heutigen
videos zu statt
ja ja also wir haben ja ein mädchen mit
einem müllsack in der hand die sie
dürfen nichts sagen und die ruft dann
ihre freundinnen und die soll jetzt
herkommen also vielleicht soll die
freundin den müll kontrollieren oder den
müll rausbringen oder so
ihre freundin kam mit einem besen nach
draußen und dann hat sie den müllsack
über den schädel gezogen
ja mach mal weiter mit dem nächsten
qualitativ hochwertigen video
[Musik]
gibt es nicht irgendeine personen der
luchs die irgendein talent besitzt
[Musik]
ok dieses mädchen hat laut luca
gezeichnet also das hier ist ja auch
luca und die finale zeichnung von ihr
sah dann so aus also ganz im ernst das
kann man wirklich als talent bezeichnen
bezeichnen
das ist lustig weil sie gezeichnet hat
[Musik]
also ich finde das bild hier beschreibt
di luco wirklich in einem foto sag mal
was habt ihr denn alle mit ihren
bobbycars ich weiß ich hab früher ein
bobbycar ihn war zu weihnachten bekommen
als ich ein kleines kind war dann bin
ich damit gegen eine seite gefahren und
dann habe ich das ding nie wieder
angerührt
ich habe kein geld habe ich auch was
sind visco girls ich frage mich das
schon seit ein paar wochen und zwar bin
ich ein bisschen aktiver wieder auf
ticks auf und sie halt überall videos
mit dem hashtag visco girl also ich
finde es mega lieb wenn einer von euch
mir das unten in den kommentaren
beantworten könnte und die beste
erklärung bekommt von mir eine packung
toastbrot zu weihnachten luke hatten
christen des ok die geküsste sind immer
cool also heraus zu gehen in ein ort
also zwei kühe gehen in einen ort ok
weiter geht's mit gleichen und datum
in den gleichen datum das habe
ein versprecher also des kürzels locker
richtig und wir schauen wir weiter ab
und ihnen die gleichen zeit und
in den gleichen zeit
okay beide um 7 uhr beide um 7 uhr also
okay zweifel laufen in den gleichen ort
in den gleichen datum in den gleichen
zeit und zwar sieben uhr
und wo es jetzt dass chris die sind in
ein wort gesagt ganz genau an einem ort
aber die sind sich nicht so die haben
keinen unfall gemacht
[Musik]
m
die diese die hatten die haben keinen
unfall gemacht wie einer ist um 7 uhr
morgens gefangener ist um sieben uhr
abends gegangen ich hab doch nicht
gesagt abends uhr morgens 7
das war jetzt das quiz
hammer hast du sonst noch irgendwas zu
sagen
laut [ __ ]
meine damen und herren an der stelle
wirkt derzeit wie die allerdings auch
beenden wenn es euch gefallen hat das
unbedingt einen daumen hoch unter dem
wie die höhe da postet auch ihr mir gern
videos auf instagram oder twitter mit
dem hashtag luca reagiert werden die
nächste folge luca reagiert kommen wollt
abonniert main kanal falls sie das nicht
verpassen wollte ist es kostenlos und
verpasst keine videos mehr begrüßt es
gelegt einen franzosen
so folgt
bisher haben meine nummer 1 ich bin ein
und alles und du bist du bist mir mehr
wert als aus und ich werde immer da sein
egal
[Musik]